KNOWING OR WHITING
PARTICIPANT IN THE RUSSIAN
PLOT.
MIKE?
>> Mike: CATHERINE HERRIDGE
AT THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
TONIGHT, CATHERINE, THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
>> Mike: CLAIMING
VINDICATION AGAIN IN THE
WAKE OF THE INDICTMENTS.
KEVIN CORKE IS OUTSIDE THE
PRESIDENT'S FLORIDA COMPOUND
TONIGHT.
GOOD EVENING, KEVIN.
>> GOOD EVENING THERE,
MICHAEL.
THIS HAS BEEN A VERY
INTERESTING DAY.
WE HAVE BEEN WATCHING ALL
THE DEVELOPMENTS AS CAN YOU
WELL IMAGINE.
NOT JUST BASED ON WHAT WE
SAW FROM ROD ROSENSTEIN BUT
ALSO WHAT WE REMEMBER THE
PRESIDENT HAD TO SAY ABOUT
THE RUSSIA INVESTIGATION OH
NOT TOO TERRIBLY LONG AGO.
>> DO YOU FEEL CONVINCED
INDICATED, MR. PRESIDENT?
>> WHILE THE PRESIDENT DID
NOT RESPOND TO SOUTHED
QUESTIONS ON CAMERA THIS
AFTERNOON, ABOUT THE
REVELATIONS THAT MORE THAN A
DOZEN RUSSIAN OPERATIVES
WERE ENGAGED IN AN EFFORT TO
INTERFERE WITH THE 2016
ELECTIONS, DID HE TAKE TO
TWITTER TO WEIGH IN.
RUSSIA STARTED APPEAR AT
THIS AMERICAN
ANIS AMERICAN
ANTI AMERICAN
ANTI-UMERICAN
ANTI-U.SRICAN
ANTI-U.S.ICAN
ANTI-U.S.CAAN
ANTI-U.S.CAMPAIGN IN 2014 LONG B
ANTI-U.S.CAMPAIGN IN 2014 LONG F
ANTI-U.S.CAMPAIGN IN 2014 LONG R
ANTI-U.S.CAMPAIGN IN 2014 LONG E
I ANNOUNCED THAT I WOULD RUN
POOR IF THE.
THE RESULTS OF THE ELECTION
WERE NOT IMPACTED.
TRAMP CAMPAIGN DID NOTHING
WRONG, NO COLLUSION.
NOTHING IN TODAY'S
INDICTMENT INDICATED ANY
AMERICANS KNOWINGLY TOOK
PART IN THE RUSSIAN SCHEME.
SARAH HUCKABEE SANDERS, THE
WHITE HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY,
ISSUED A STATEMENT.
IT READ, IN PART:  PRESIDENT
DONALD J. TRUMP HAS BEEN
FULLY BRIEFED ON THIS MATTER
AND IS GLAD TO HE SOOT
SPECIAL COUNSEL'S
INVESTIGATION FURTHER
INDICATE THAT THERE WAS NO
COLLUSION BETWEEN THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN AND RUSSIA AND THAT
THE OUTCOME OF THE ELECTION
WAS NOT CHANGED OR AFFECTED.
PREVIOUSLY MR. TRUMP CALLED
THE INVESTIGATION A
WITCH-HUNT.
EVEN TWEETED ONCE THAT IT
WAS A, QUOTE HOAX, BUT
TONIGHT THERE IS PROOF THAT
THERE WAS AN EFFORT TO
RUSSIANS IN OUR ELECTION.
EVEN SO FAR THERE HAS BEEN
NO PROOF THAT ANYONE
INVOLVED IN THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN HAD ANYTHING TO DO
WITH IT MAJOR CHANGES HOW
THE WHITE HOUSE WILL HANDLE
SECURITY CLEARANCE
INVESTIGATIONS IN THE
FUTURE.
WE LEARNED ABOUT THIS TODAY.
IT'S A FIVE PAGE DOCUMENT,
AND IT BASICALLY LAYS OUT
THE OVERHALL IN THIS WAY
FOLLOW UP ON ONGOING
INVESTIGATIONS.
WE ARE TOLD THAT DON MCGAHN
THE WHITE HOUSE CHIEF
COUNSEL ALSO HELPED TO WRITE
THIS OVERHAUL ALONGSIDE JOHN
KELLY.
AGAIN, THIS IS A BIT OF A
FALLOUT FROM THE ROB PORTER
CIRCUMSTANCE.
OF COURSE THE FORMER WHITE
HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY WHO,
OF COURSE, WAS FIRED NOT